for team that went to the finals five
years in a row and won three diamonds
there's Duncan Robinson setting up for a
three coming more comfortable putting it
down on the deck and and driving it
there I like how Kendrick played I'm
kind of faked Adam stayed off doing a
top five rookie scores a group we will
shine the spotlight on later tonight
Robinson straightaway three all ready
for this opening quarter
the average is 10 again well Rockets
made the defender tumble hero Hill
Massachusetts that is Boston College
Eagles Kings undrafted he's on a two-way
deal he's on a one-way ticket took
three-point heaven
here he comes off a hard cut great
dribble handoff action defense is right
there look a hand right in front but
Duncan doesn't even feel them right
there
[Applause]
two triples and ten points off the
banners have not yet led in this game my
greens pass broken up stolen by poplar
the lead for ban net warriors get that
quickly Duncan Robinson steps in the
[Applause]
[Music]
Warriors got within six earlier the
school hero from downtown yes sixteen
point
Heatley hero off the shot finish fires
from three three point he'd leave
that'll block by the silver hammer a
Christian foolish 13th block of his
rookie season there's hero
[Applause]